this week we've got fast food fight I
know this one you do updated monopoly
don't know this one and scooters beaten
just the personnel without a three huh
yo which one is it Gia the ketchup no
it's the [ __ ] bacon whatever no I
don't know anything
do you guys know do you guys know
McDonald's we got this new [ __ ]
McGriddle that's like four five six
seven layers now Oh what two patties and
[ __ ] a hash brown in the middle what
yeah what - McDonald's the other day and
I was like did you get it no did you get
it cuz I was right before scoop I don't
want to throw up into my [ __ ] good so
this story it takes place at a water
burger oh my god is another restaurant
Frank like a video of one no so this one
it takes place near Houston and there
were two high schools that got into this
huge food fight right after this game -
hi hold on dude fight at a place where
you just paid for the food I know right
like in the cafeteria at school like my
mom paid for that I'm gonna have fun
with my mom's money you know but when
egos get involved or rival schools
someone throws a french fry and you're
like where do you mean mom [ __ ] the
pigeons well [ __ ] the seals and they
start throwing at each other pigeons
what a sorry mascot I know dude it's
between the Falcons and the Wolverines
this is see that's a lot better than
something like that I'm bird and a
[ __ ] dog looking creature staples is
the only one that has a dough pigeon the
score here for this football game was 28
to 6 oh yeah Falcons beat Wolverines and
there's thank happens people will worry
whoo
this is a video that went viral my
school mascot beat a pinto bean the
pinto bean lots of protein Oh
oh that's fun is elbow damn I feel bad
for the workers though people are
wasting so much money what are y'all
doing yeah they're getting kicked out
too oh right right well you know kids
you know we were all kids and that
energy of a kid is very close to of a
chimpanzee yeah once things happen it
just erupts
I'm sure someone threw [ __ ] I'm sure I
was way too poor every way to port and
waiting fat
mmhc would have not had everybody
would've started throwing food I would
have caught burgers ba ba our lunch
dinner breakfast dude it was a bit of
[ __ ] like you're a wide receiver Asia
Judy food fights never turn out like the
movies yeah it never happened yeah well
me in elementary school what happened
imagine somebody throwing an apple it
doesn't land like most of it is just
flying all over the place and it gets
stopped immediately yeah not my hair
Bobby I've been burning up because every
food fight I've ever seen turned into a
fist fight Rumble I've never seen like
injustice ever seen a food fight well I
don't know if it's food how did your
guys start well I don't remember how it
starts yeah it's literally one person
throws if they're like what the [ __ ] and
then they throw it back and then it was
yeah and then you just keep going yeah
only food fights I've ever been in my
life where a JK party uh that's how it
starts literally but that was small
scale but then like we're all friends
and they'll care about each other I'm
thinking like how does it happen we like
I didn't know literally the same way
that it happened it's like one person
[ __ ] Ron and then I was like oh really
and then people get when you find that
hole nothing that's french fries we're
like like in the movies or like TV shows
were like the whole school gets involved
it was usually like two groups yeah yeah
yeah and everyone else is just like
don't get my clothes dirty
today dude if I didn't throw any food I
would see weight for everybody get
kicked out now I just be eating
everybody food yeah yeah cuz it's all
untouched the ones that didn't get
thrown it's like that's brand new damn
hop forward dude I didn't get to eat a
lot of Americans he's just hungry I'm
what David though I'm hungry and I like
American food yeah I just like I like
Sam like I'm not always hungry but like
I just need a little taste of everything
so like I just want to know what that
tastes like
and I don't know what that is like and
this did you guys ever have eating
competitions no ajq party no no like at
school so I junior high were like
alright guys let's have like a like a
eat off that's good guys think girls can
save up money and we're like alright by
Friday everybody save up like don't buy
as much lunch so that so then we can all
like just pitch in and get like every
single thing on the menu
let's see if we could like finish it
finish it they were my friends were
going to pay me to eat a box-to-box of
the Costco pizza two boxes of them I had
a box and a half a pizza dude you are a
science experiment to them well I would
have got a lot of money I forgot what
the amount was oh [ __ ] so you finished
that and they came you know I didn't get
the money cuz I did you did you have to
pay for the pizzas I know okay yeah my
meal was Costco people to eight bucks
for two of them so it was like 16 bucks
split between like [ __ ] ten dudes
it's pretty cheap and you got to move it
like you're moving a coffee table in
your house to still heavier reason I
thought I could do it it was not
possible I went through a phase where I
thought I wanted to do competitive
eating I saw this what was that guy's
name the guy that eats a hot dogs I
think his name's like Kobayashi yeah
yeah yeah I watched like a video him
doing that I was like wow that's so cool
he can just unhinge his jaw and just eat
all that food I wish I could do that now
I'm thing about how unattractive that
would be if like a female was really
into competitive there's a lot of
females really yeah they're not
attractive yeah they're not disgusting
either some of them are I mean some of
the guys but I mean like imagine like
you meet a girl and like you know she's
just like she's like oh yeah I do like
competitive eating you're like [ __ ]
we're you know yeah they do look like
that yeah there are some girls that are
like straight up they look small yeah
and they could take a look impound
doing hot wings or just wings they just
go like boom and then the bone is just
out oh yeah I saw that one I thought
well hot wings competition and one of
the girls on there she was like a blonde
chick she was really pretty another
thing she does not look and she was
really petite too I don't know like like
if the girls like super attractive and
then like said then she find out she's
like a competitive eater does that is
that a plus or is it a negative depends
because most guys are looking at her
boobs in her but she eats too much food
looking at the boobs in the pipe we're
gonna be kind of like a plus though cuz
they you know she oh Jesus yeah I think
depends on the guy what they think
because there's guys out there that
don't like food and don't care about it
and they don't want to eat that much so
then you know if the girl friends like
just eating there all day they're
waiting they're like Oh cuz when I find
attractive that is just they're
competitive in general so if someone's a
competitive basket weaver like that my
last type because they're passionate
about something he doesn't have to be
food it could just be competitive
anything cry next story monopoly or
Hasbro to be specific they have this new
monopoly of called monopoly for
Millennials
what are they [ __ ] with us equal
opportunity monopoly or some [ __ ] yeah
and so everyone starts off with a
million dollars millennia when it's
forget real estate you can't afford it
anyway gonna be some like [ __ ] so
it's based in LA then because if you go
to other states it's still affordable
man they made it for Millennials maybe
it's still not affordable for them oh
yeah yeah cuz their minimum wages lower
to uh I don't think people understand
like the disparity and like wealth like
in certain places right so for example
Africa where I read this but somebody
was the saying like they Bay they make
about eighty thousand a year like in LA
right and they're like yeah you know I
do okay you know I mean in people like
ok you must be so rich I was like eighty
that you have to realize [ __ ] Kansas
boy like haha yeah
like a TK to you if I'm [ __ ] weak
being in her mouth yeah some people live
in states where there's no income tax
exactly so it's sort of a ghast here
you don't mean double tax are [ __ ]
cost of living is high and our food is
expensive do so just stop moving here
too you don't want to live here
doubles going yes not pursuing your
dreams trying to be an actor and don't
move here start up online and then move
to LA when you film move to LA no it's
already crowded but if it's not normal
people that's a move in here it's
[ __ ] rich people or for money too
yeah they're really [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
yeah so back to the novel here's what
she does all move out together that
players don't win with money to buy
homes or railroads but instead they
collect experience points by earning
rewards such as three-day Music Festival
or going to a vegan Bistro because oh
dear Lord
wait so how do they make money God do
they develop apps and [ __ ] they
Instagram how that'll be interesting
because like the game of Monopoly is to
be a tycoon is to own the whole thing
and then make money off of everyone and
win so so you're you know you wrote you
own all the railroads you own all the
[ __ ] apartments and you turn them
into I mean the homes and determinantal
hotels and all that [ __ ] yeah but
instead of property it's experiences
that's how for this game might be the
park is wait is a boardwalk park or Park
Place on a boardwalk is probably you've
reached half a million Instagram
followers yeah yeah I got to see this
[ __ ] so there's like couchsurfing and
then the little touch all about
experiences do we should play this a
cheeky party or hashtag a globe is there
like a backpacking through Europe also
I'm sorry question do they not realize
that I don't know is this Millennials
this sounds more like people that are 20
years old
hmm you know like 2021 and like we're
too late
see yeah this gen Z yeah cuz that I
don't know that I don't know if that's
us fam cuz a lot of us over the whole
like Instagram and like all that jazz
where they're saying because a lot of
Millennials they're not like traditional
where they will stick to the 905 job
forever like they'll quit their job and
they'll go traveling we are doing kind
of millennial [ __ ] no we're like the
earlier Millennials dawg I think so yeah
like we're doing all those stereotypical
things like we create we're in the
digital world we create our own jobs
we're not sticking to the 9 of 5 things
we're not doing all the expected things
that our parents generations did yeah we
like Millennials do prioritize
experiences over money
according to yeah I believe that because
I rather go traveling and a lot of other
things and time time is more important
than like property or money I don't know
about that if I could afford property I
get property yeah there's an oh man you
know what's crazy i watch i read this
recent thing about the value of like how
much college was how much homes were how
much cars were during our parents
generation and then they did like a what
do you call it like they accounted for
inflation for the dollar amount and all
that it was like way [ __ ] cheaper
like a car was like you could have you
pay it off in like a year a car was like
three grand or something thank you yeah
and even if you change it with it with
the inflation now and all that you could
pay it you could pay off that car like
in a year or two home was like you could
pay off pay pay it off in like five
years or some [ __ ] like that it was
really it was really affordable yeah now
cars are like five or six years to pay
off now in the early 2000s in early
2000s a regular two to three bedroom
house out here in LA was a hundred
thousand dollars that's only ten years
ago or no 15 years ago so yeah but it's
like you yeah that's $100,000 the as
time goes on like let's say like in the
70s or 80s like the marketing people and
the people that set the price once they
start getting smarter and the narrative
is constantly for decades they need it
they'll pay for it they need it they'll
pay for it so ever you
it just keeps creeping on up because
they know that we need it and we have no
choice but to pay for it so as the
industry standard for the minimum goes
up it's just gonna keep rising and like
I'll see a reason for it to get any
lower which is kind of scary yeah I was
watching a couple of people who are like
minimalist you know any mean that's like
damn I really wish I could do what they
do you know cuz they literally wear the
same [ __ ] every day
they have like a [ __ ] drawer full of
the same t-shirts I draw for the same
pants and they don't really have a lot
of excess I would like to try to do that
and I was like looking good the stuff
that I could get rid of I'm not doing it
that retired at 29 yeah and they can
they don't have to work ever again
high-paying jobs and then they planned
it all out and then they they saved 80%
of their income and they only lived on
20% husband and wife ESCO there forever
living minimalist yeah they're they're
all they're only doing that and then
they also invested a lot so eighty to
ninety percent of their income was in
different stocks and so they only
withdraw about four to seven percent
every year of their stocks so for the
rest of the their lifetime now they
could just live off of that if I was
doing that well I would keep going till
I was 40 and then retire out like 40 you
know so like I could live like a little
nicer but they they well their point was
they wanted to live that style so they
could spend a hundred percent family
life with the kids and all that stuff
it in so starting this yeah girl that
they had to be like late 20s early 30s
so then they can be with the kids and
stuff everyone's definition minimal is
different to mine includes having an
archery range in my backyard wow that's
not well you could technically do that
if you lived in the country but he'll
you know it has to be in LA where it's
close to a lot of downtown boom that's
what I mean it's minimal it's my last
story this fifteen-year-old boy got six
points on his future driving license or
speeding on a scooter
yeah on a scooter though that's not part
of the okay wait actually let's think
about this in the UK oh he's a danger to
society yeah if he doesn't even have a
license in it and he's already out here
trying to kill somebody with a scooter
yeah cuz he would I respond scible she
was how fast was he going like forty
miles an hour or something oh no she
didn't you add a motor it's like one of
those like you know like the birds or
whatever like those kind of scooters
electrics those things can go 40 no
that's what I was thinking because it
shows you the speed on the little like
the little pad and I remember I was
going 70 miles an hour
you know like when you said 40 I'm like
I was like breakneck speed going down
Wilshire I was terrified
I can't imagine 40 and he's enough of a
sociopath that he kept going - mm-hmm
yeah how to stop them yeah well they
look like this this kid needs to be
developed Shaun White needs to hit him
up and develop him for the next great
snowboarder oh this is wind so these
ones go faster huh that kind of scooter
make different companies oh you're
thinking always picturing a sit-down
regular scooter yeah make sure one
another electric scooters like a moped
right yeah yeah that's what your bird
yeah don't say I was I'm telling you
TIFF breakneck speed 17 miles per hour I
cannot fathom 40 oh that's dangerous 40
on that little pebble the wrong way your
ass is [ __ ] that calm Saint this
guy's so good Shawn why it needs to find
his dude and develop him he could be the
next great skateboarder snowboarder
fearless yes the man is fearless at 40
you can die that's why it's 25 in a
school zone yeah he was flying on that
thing especially the street okay I'll be
got our cobblestones and [ __ ] you know
what I actually saw this morning I got
brick roads and [ __ ]
taking up well it happened too fast I
couldn't take your photo but this
morning I saw this dude like this huge
grown-ass man on one of those like super
tiny little motorcycles but like like a
pocket bike no what are those cause it
looks like an actual like motorcycle
looks like hyemi for the good tiles yeah
pocket bike I don't know I don't know
their biggest bromance the funniest
thing to like when I see you know those
[ __ ] like Kawasaki like [ __ ] the
crotch rockets yeah but then the dudes
like 400 pound he's riding it I feel so
bad for the motors I feel it's like a
horse you are killing that machine do
you remember those two really fat guys
that would ride motorcycles and then
they're like famous like they they would
be at fairs and the Orange County custom
suits no it was like too obese twins
that wrote little motorcycles and then
they were like cowboys want that huh
Harley and David this is an old
reference yeah yeah six points cuz I
once he actually has his driver's
license he only has like six more points
before he takes it away they take it
away Birds look super fun but Birds
[ __ ] annoy the [ __ ] out of me dude
why because these [ __ ] are
always in the [ __ ] Road and everybody
has to [ __ ] wait for them yeah you
can't you can't ride them on the
sidewalks like you can't in like that
you also wear helmets in California it
seems like you're supposed to not write
it unless you have a helmet oh yeah but
that's also corny have you rented one
before yeah I can't I didn't rent one
because I've talked so much [ __ ] about
them yeah so I don't want to be a
hypocrite
I love razor scooters Oh razor scooters
yeah but the birds yeah I mean because
they they have to be on the road like a
[ __ ] vehicle there's a dangerous so
it's like we're behind this thing that's
going like 10 miles an hour and we just
have to wait and so like people are just
honking honking like it's like oh you
know it was crazy they got banned and
they got banned in Hollywood and Beverly
Hills
suburbs yeah like there the map is
literally red like you and they're like
it will cut off like you cannot ride it
into those areas in a few places other
like other places are trying to ban them
- who's calling traffic yeah well
Emily Hills just did their bougie and
they just didn't like what they look
like having all these little flock oh
yeah sitting around on the side it's
like I get it that is kind of tacky you
like think oh yeah then people just
leave I'm like on the floor yeah is that
how it works like you swipe her credit
card you can write it anywhere just drop
it off yeah and I've seen some people
like gut them like on the side of the
road like you'll see one like like just
yes one on the side of the road missing
a wheel like some kind of [ __ ] pulled
out of the console missing a handlebar
bird on the side streets give me help me
help me you know and you just gotta walk
right by it
oh that's funny
[Music]